ce sont les rois du swing électro et
vous vous êtes arracher leur dernier
album intitulé clash en concert ils vous
font revenus et les gambettes et vous ne
résistez pas à leur extraordinaire
énergie scénique
attention ils sont là tout de suite
maintenant c'est pour vous voici caravan
palace dans le kiosque
à l'origine en fait c'est une chaîne de
télévision française qui diffuse un
petit peu de porno qui voulait faire un
pilote en fait des missions pour
réhabiliter les films porno des années
20 donc été des films illégaux à
l'époque
et voilà comme il voulait redonner un
peu de vie et de nouveauté à tout ça
nous avait demandé de enfin vu qu'on
était dans le swing de faire un truc qui
pourrait se rapprocher de ça et c'est là
on a mélangé le swing traditionnel des
musiques électroniques
et voilà ça a donné caravane on faisait
chacun dans notre coin de la musique
électronique mais sans vraiment avoir
projet enfin qui a abouti quoi à côté de
ça on venait du jazz manouche tous les
trois on a eu envie de mélanger les deux
on a essayé donc avec cette opportunité
d'un film porno
mélange d'anciens donc de son ancien un
peu crado et de musique électronique
pour le coup beaucoup plus propre et est
très produit deuxième album est plus
électronique
en fait c'est c'est venu naturellement
voilà c'est juste que quand on a fait le
premier album on était peut-être sur la
balance on était plus dans la musique
acoustique et assure ce deuxième plus
dans la musique électronique voilà c'est
les goûts du moment qu'ils font que
naturellement on fait varier les choses
s'est il n'y a pas deux il n'y avait pas
de calcul en fait
il ya un truc qui me dérangeait sur
premier album c'est que il y avait pas
vraiment d'unités sonores ont trouvé
quelquefois par exemple on entend une
clarinette mais on n'entend que c'est
une farine est très moderne qui a été
rajoutée par dessus et puis au fond il
ya un vieux samples il peut y avoir une
partie de batteries kisan années 50 mais
et puis en même temps un charleston qui
serait plus modernes voire électronique
ciselé quoi et à ses actions le deuxième
album on a essayé de d'harmoniser tous à
niveau sonore surtout notamment au
niveau des voix on a beaucoup travaillé
pour que les voix on sache pas vraiment
si c'est la chanteuse c'est un simple et
c est de même avec les instruments donc
on aime bien ça donne vraiment ce côté
rétro futuriste
le travail de studio en effet de
réadapter ça en live vu que comme tu le
disais fait c'est enfin c'est très
travaillé très très arrangé et tout donc
on essaye de réarranger ça de jouer les
lignes de synthés ce qui n'est pas
forcément évident au début mais on
essaye de tours est adapté d'un peut
exploser les structures pour le truc
plus vivant sur scène c'est assez c'est
vrai c'est un peu la fête
enfin surtout c'est très énergique c'est
ce qu'on cherche beaucoup plus ça par
rapport à l'album de l'album on va être
beaucoup plus pointues sur les sons sur
les structures ce genre de choses et
alors que sur scène on va toujours
chercher à sortir le plus d'énergie et
peut-être de spontanéité c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur la différence
entre à l'ordinateur est jouée live
instruments donc voilà d'ocana qui
préfèrent le groupe en studio et
d'autres sur scène
là
c
roxane on nous voit jouer donc les gens
comprennent ce qu'on joue alors qu'on
studio c'est vrai que c'est tellement un
micmac de plein de petits sont donc on a
un peu du mal à isoler telle somme qui
fait quoi et tout ça notre chanteuse que
lüthi zoo est une bête de scène
s'écoulant pour nous aussi c'est ça nous
ça nous pousse un peu parce que mon à
l'origine il n'a quand même plutôt des
rad studio
et
m
on va travailler sur sur le troisième
album toute façon dès qu'on arrête de
tourner et on retourne en studio on
n'applique pas ce qui va sortir un
nouveau clip
ouf après cet électrochoc qu'on retrouve
un tout nouveau sujet de la rédaction
avec johanna soudry à l'ego gurria
labour la faille aller moi je suis
arrivé en 2004 le groupe il existait il
existait depuis on va dire 99 2000 mais
pour de vrai sur les sur scène depuis
depuis 2001 2002 quoi c'est un groupe
qui tourne et voilà quand je suis arrivé
dans le groupe ça tournait ça commençait
à tourner bien depuis un an ou deux les
fatals picards un groupe qui conjugue
humour et musique avec des textes
engagés
traversant différents styles musicaux il
s'en prend tantôt au punk tantôt au
reggae en fait il n'y a pas de style
musical particulier par rapport aux par
rapport au groupe et en est que disons
que le cahier des charges dans des
fatals picards c'est plus de la musique
humoristique
donc en fait après la musique dépendra
du texte choisi il ya des chansons un
petit peu premier degré qui voilà qui
qui sont bien avec une musique un petit
peu plus rock un petit peu plus punk d
il ya des textes un petit peu plus on va
dire sensible aux nostalgiques mais qui
souffre qui vont plus avec une
orchestration un peu plus chanson
française parlons-en de la chanson
française en 2007 les musiciens
représente l'hexagone au concours de
l'eurovision avec l'amour à la française
le wat et toi t'es fait avoir
je ne suis pas de calais
pas et rend les
les fatals picards se produiront le 20
octobre sur la scène de la bri blues à
bois d'arcy le groupe achève sa deuxième
année de tournée pour l'album coming out
avant de sortir un nouvel opus en 2013
la scène devient une zone test pour de
nouveaux morceaux
c
des colons
plus de deux mois
et
c'est vrai que depuis quelques temps on
essaie d'incorporer dans notre
répertoire des nouvelles chansons qu'on
va sortir l'année prochaine pour voir un
petit peu quelle est la réaction du
public voir si si c'est là on va pouvoir
les exploiter c'est uniquement parce
qu'on s'est rendu compte au fil du temps
qu'il ya des chansons qui qui fonctionne
très bien randy ce qui est moins bien
sur scène et alain vert s'est séparé
quoi donc voilà ce qu'on va voir à bois
d'arcy c'est ça c'est beaucoup de
chansons de notre dernier album
enfin beaucoup de chansons des trois
derniers on va piocher un peu dans le
répertoire beaucoup plus vieux mais de
manière un peu plus anecdotique
et puis quelques nouvelles chansons
quelques nouveaux titres
voilà donc on commence à jouer donc ils
sont ce qu'on va dire qu'ils sont frais
mais qui sont faites pas aussi careï que
les trucs qu'on joue plus
et encore quelques dates à noter avant
d'aller ramasser des marrons la batterie
nous proposera le 20 octobre un concert
de la folkeuse suzanne vega le 23
octobre le trompettiste italien enrico
rava s'illustrera dans très beau théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines tandis que
les 24 25 et 26 octobre sandrine anglade
nous proposera le roi du bois avec
l'extraordinaire jacques bonnaffé à la
ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt
les amoureux de chansons quant à eux
pourront retrouver alexis hk le 24
octobre à la batterie à guyancourt et
ceux qui aiment le jazz manouche électro
retrouverons les caravan palace le 25
octobre au prisme et n'oubliez pas que
tous les mardis vous pouvez gagner des
places de spectacle sur le site du
kiosque www.kia.ca qui point fr des
dates que vous pouvez retrouver sur
internet aux adresses qui s'affiche
alors bon spectacle à tous et à bientôt
le cachet de la balle